okay so getting into Jason Aaron's Thor
god of thunder I guess you know last
days of Midgard just stories actually
split into it's really kind of
interesting the way this is done is
because the the part but we're going to
be focusing on here is Thor fighting
Galactus since that's the part you guys
care about the other half of this is
basically setting a stage for like rocks
on oil to get involved with with
Malekith and his desire to launch his
war of nine realms and so on and so
forth and we'll grab back around to that
because that's really kind of like ends
Jason Aaron's run but we will wrap back
around to this once we pick back up with
Thor with the release of Ragnarok so
we've been a little while we've got a
little bit of time before we jump back
into Thor again there's we might start
our x-men run and then like pause the
x-men run or Thor Ragnarok and and do
all the four stories going up to this
which is Jason Aaron's run and then go
back into x-men again because there's no
chronological series of videos on the
x-men stories after the events of house
of M but we'll cross that bridge once we
get to it one thing to keep in mind and
I'm really kind of debating on whether
or not this is something that we're
going to cover because it's not wildly
significant it's just a thing he did in
the future but essentially
earth itself is completely uninhabited
because of the fact that Loki basically
obliterated all life on the planet now
this was covered in Loki agent of Asgard
and Loki agent of Asgard was basically
designed to kind of emphasize his
character the problem with doing that is
and wouldn't understand why blokey agent
of Asgard happened we have to understand
why he's young again why he's trying to
change his ways and in order understand
why he's trying to change his ways we
have to understand why he was a little
boy while he was a chick all that stuff
comes out of thor ragnarok
so again Ragnarok was kind of like the
House of M are kind of like the the
reboot so to speak because of that all
we really need to know is that Loki
basically obliterated all life on earth
and that was really all there is but
what this did is it set the stage for
the arrival of Galactus now keep in mind
this section of the story takes place
millions of years or at least maybe not
millions but thousands and thousands of
years in the future so even if humanity
hadn't been wiped out by Loki it
certainly would have died off it's so
important on the line but the fact
remains here that Galactus is still
again very much alive now this really
and it'll probably drag a lot of
questions in the fray this really kind
of throws them to sharp relief the
nature of secret wars now something that
I want to point out here is how Secret
Wars fits into the chronology of events
in Marvel Comics and this is where model
tends to contradict itself in mobile
comics you have a character in the
cable and cable is a guy that hails from
the future the guy is a retconning
machine essentially if Marvel wants to
change something don't have cable just
suddenly travel back in time for
whatever reason and he's like I'm here
to prevent this from happening
case in point civil war when the
original Civil War didn't happen cable
and Deadpool still had their team-up
comic cable jumped into the past and
said hey look mr. president if you do
this I know where this is going to lead
to and you're not going to like it so
it's basically kind of fitting it in and
so the issue with cables character is
everything that happens between right
now at any given point in Marvel Comics
and the future is all part of cables
timeline the issue with this and the
reason why it's so important is because
in this particular story we're kind of
left to believe that had Secret Wars not
happened then this series of events
would have transpired some you know five
six seven thousand years in the future
and so the best way to think about this
is that whenever you pick up a Marvel
story and it says thousands of years in
the future or something like that and
it's a story that took place before
secret worst then basically just act as
though that story took place as if
secret wars never happened and for
whatever reason Secret Wars ended up
taking place and so because that is
really the only way we have to kind of
rectify these two things and sort of
bring them together but the fact remains
here remember for the character of Thor
Midgard which is basically earth had
been his home for quite some time now of
course again this really all kind of
cycles back to Ragnarok in and of itself
but at the same time it's also just the
idea of him having been a superhero on
her fought alongside being real Captain
America and Incredible Hulk and so many
different superheroes you know having
met Jane Foster there having been a
friend to humanity in so many different
ways it's really kind of him just sort
of losing a piece of himself and so what
for routinely does is he travels back to
earth for no other reason than to just
kind of gather his bearings and this is
kind of you know paying homage to the
world
they gave him so much and it's sort of
mourn over the friends that he's lost
because of the actions of Loki the
problem with this is that Thor alongside
his granddaughter's basically showing up
here if suddenly met would be a rival of
Galactus now for Thor this is as much an
affront as it is really the final battle
because remember as it stands right now
in terms of like the old gods so to
speak which is to say those who lived on
Asgard as far back as Asgard goes the
idea here is that Thor is really the
last of the old Asgardians and earth is
the last refuge it's really the one
thing that he can't let go and so
because of this he acts
he banishes his granddaughter's away now
this makes sense because you have to
keep in mind in the mind of Thor he's
fought Galactus so many times and while
his granddaughter's know who Galactus is
they are not prepared for the you know
the kind of power that Galactus
possesses now something else to point
out here is Jason Aaron didn't just
arbitrarily grab the likeness he wasn't
just sitting in like you know what I
think we should have some kind of a
villain who are we going to use well
let's use Galactus and truth Galactus
and Thor go way back and just in the
realm of Marvel Comics the origin of the
laches first appeared in the four comics
I want to say was 161 and 162 the fact
remains here that with guard stood two
Galactus and fourth their history is
extremely rich I mean they fought side
by side to defeat ego the Living Planet
they've been enemies and they've been
allies and so because of this Thor is
well aware of how powerful Galactus is
but Thor is not without his own
capabilities keep in mind Thor is
currently in possession of the four
force now when it comes to to the
Asgardian mythos when it comes to Marvel
comics the concept of the odinforce or
the Thor force whatever you want to call
it it's simply just a source of power
it's not like it is a well it's
basically just the power he possesses
now with Odin it's a little more
straightforward with Odin his brothers
had previously died alongside Odin
facing off against Surtur which is kind
of like this mortal enemy it's the
archenemy of Odin and he's actually the
guy that killed Odin going into Ragnarok
but the fact remains here that the the
Brothers of Odin basically died and
their life force merged with him and
gave him the odinforce and so it was
really kind of Marvel's way to just
explain here's why Odin is so powerful
and so it's almost as if it was just
kind of powers of this that were
bestowed upon him but again it's still
kind of murky it's not really clear-cut
there's no definitive explanations now
this is something that can be passed on
from person to person so it's almost
like a power that he can remove from
himself and give to somebody else it's
actually what happened during the events
of Ragnarok for basically spoke directly
with the odinforce so it is an actual
tangible source of energy they can exist
outside of Odin it's just with Odin all
the time and so whatever uses it to its
completion or uses any fraction of it he
has to go into the odinsleep to
basically recharge that power but the
fact remains here that Thor you know
what Odin having died somewhere along
the line
Thor is now in possession of this source
of energy and so effectively he now has
to Thor force and this is insane
because the Odin or Thor force basically
allows either one to do whatever it is
that they want to do at any particular
point in time shy of warping reality on
a universal scale it basically just
amplifies their existing powers in the
extreme the funny thing about this
though is that as powerful as Thor is
he's not on the same level as Galactus
because wherever Galactus is a force of
nature I mean you're talking about a
being with hit or two unrivaled power
for the exception of the highest-ranking
cosmic entities and even then today dare
not try to destroy Galactus because if
the lactis were in a hundred state let's
say for example if Galactus was
basically ravenous he was absolutely
feeding you know he was dying for
something to eat he could probably lay
waste to a litany of different things
but if the lactis is completely full if
Galactus is totally charged with energy
you know if you were a battery and he's
at 100% I would dare say there's almost
no one who could stand in his way
barring maybe eternity himself and even
then it would probably be a pretty
formidable challenge and so because of
that you know Galactus is not someone to
be trifled with here now the cool thing
is to get this really really beautiful
conversation between the two of them and
the idea here is that you know Thor's
question is why are you going to consume
this world this world is half dead I
mean it'll only ever give you really
half the sustenance you need it would be
like eating a half-eaten sandwich why
eat a half-eaten sandwich we can go eat
a whole sandwich go to another planet
that's less rich with life take that
planet there's no reason for you to take
earth but for Galactus it's more than
just consuming a planet right like it's
more than just saying well I'm hungry
right now I'm gonna go eat a planet or
the lattice it's consuming earth because
remember the lattice and earth have a
very close history I mean Galactus is
first appearance you know in Marvel
Comics came by way of the Silver Surfer
arriving on earth telling the Fantastic
Four Galactus is coming and he's going
to consume your planet and there's
nothing you can do to stop him and then
you know the Silver Surfer and the
Fantastic Four banding together to
defeat Galactus by way of using the
ultimate nullifier or at least
threatening to use the ultimate
nullifier but time and time again
Galactus has shown up on earth with the
intention to conquer and time and time
again the earth superheroes had
basically stopped him and so furgle
actus is basically saying I finally get
the planet that I've been wanting to
consume this entire time it is not
necessarily a life rich planet this
planet has basically died and but for me
it's really more just the principle of
the thing you know and that's kind of
the irony here because what it does is
it really shows
powerful earth was in a lot of different
ways and that was something that had
been touched on time and time again I
mean danos has referenced that over and
over again the different alien races and
mobile comics at some point along the
line the Shiar Empire decree the scrolls
near the badoon they've all talked about
that time and time again the earth is
home to some of the universe's most
powerful beings but the earth is also
filled with people who still live in a
very primitive capacity which is to say
politics run the show and different
things like that and so the earth was
always viewed as a very dangerous place
because if one of the superheroes like
Franklin Richards managed to lose
control of his powers he could wipe out
everything in existence to say nothing
of people like the molecule man Owen
Reese so again it's really kind of a
cool scenario here with regards to the
nature of the earth and how it all
functions now of course this leads into
a direct conflict between Thor himself
as well as Galactus and so again this is
really kind of cool because it's
basically like this Last Stand it's
really for doing everything he can to
try to keep this planet alive the
problem here is that it's capable as
Thor is at the end of the day he's no
Odin he's basically being toppled at
every single turn now in some ways we
could say this is Jason there and just
nerfing the power of the of the Thor
force just sitting down and saying okay
look you know we're going to reduce this
power and it's not nearly on the same
level as Odin and to a degree that might
be the case I would say this is just
Jason Aaron writing a story for the sake
of writing a great story which is
exactly what he does is absolutely
amazing but in the middle of all this
Thor again going head-to-head against
Galactus is ultimately toppled and
actually just kind of kicked off the
planet and just sort of sent flying now
again this is cool because in despite
the fact that Thor is not as powerful as
Odin was it's still an incredible fight
Galactus is relishing in this right I
mean when you're Galactus and you've
been traveling around the universe for
billions of years and you show up on
somebody's planet and they fire off your
little weapons which ten amounts of
throwing toothpicks at a hurricane you
kind of get bored of the idea that no
one can put up a real challenging fight
but then here you come to earth you know
trying to conquer this planet it stood
against you for so long and then you
find one god left with an insane amount
of power and you relish in the challenge
you're like finally you know I have
somebody to keep me entertained so it's
really kind of a cool scenario of course
one store is basically kind of cast out
of earth or cast out of Midgard and sent
into the depths of space it allows
Galactus to begin going through and
consuming the planet
again the cool thing about this is that
while all this is happening we're
suddenly met with the arrival of Thor's
granddaughters now in my rundown video
this is one of the funny things was like
hey guys you're back from shopping but
this is one of the coolest moments in
the story because Thor's granddaughters
are badass but not only that one of them
looks like they're wielding Stormbreaker
now store breaker for those of you guys
who don't know is basically the hammer
of beta ray bill and beta ray bill the
reason why fans love him so much and the
reason why so many people are like put
him in the Marvel Cinematic Universe is
because beta ray bill is the first
person to have ever picked up Thor's
hammer and it was a huge moment when it
happened Nick Fury contact Thor says hey
look there's a ship coming over here to
earth Thor goes to investigate you know
beta ray bill basically as part of his
race or at least as one of his uh as as
races main protector you know the
protector of the korbinites comes across
Thor fights against him and then picks
up this hammer it was mind-blowing he
was just like oh my god that's never
happened before so it was a great big
huge moment and it set the stage for
Marvel to begin introducing these
moments here and there when someone
other than Thor picked his him or up but
it was always a really really cool
moment whenever it happened but because
of the regime that had taken place
Odin had basically hosted a contest
between beta ray bill and Thor to
determine who was the most worthy and
because of the fact that beta ray bill
had proved himself to be an honorable
warrior because his conflict with Thor
was not due to villainy but because of
the fact that he was a protector beta
ray bill was given his own hammer
fashioned by the dwarves at the request
of Odin and was called storm breakers so
again it's a really really cool moment
of course there's the action arm drawn
there's the mace I mean there's all
different kinds of little trinkets and
so on and it really kind of shows as the
Thor really is the last of the God there
are no other gods left in terms of the
traditional Pantheon the cosmic entities
still exist out there but at the end of
the day the grandaughters authority not
necessarily able to topple Galactus and
we wouldn't expect them to they're able
to put up a pretty significant fight a
lot more than we would expect a much
greater conflict than we would expect to
see here now again this is really kind
of Jason Aaron delving into the idea
that there are still really those
individuals out there that a part of the
Asgardian pantheon that do the best they
can in terms of holding off various
threats but it's also the notion that
the granddaughters are for follow very
much in his footsteps they're just as
capable as he is in terms of straight-up
battles and so of course following this
quick little skirmish between them we
end up coming back to Thor himself and
finding out that here
actually transitions to the Purvis part
or ends up in the third the furthest
part of the universe work or the god
butcher had essentially been left you
know where he had been destroyed with
the necros sword just sort of sitting
out there in the middle of nowhere and
so what this does is it basically allows
Thor to grab this sword kind of
harkening back to when he had absorbed
the sword and when he had both hammers
at the same time and really just kind of
realized this is basically the only way
to take out Galactus to basically use
the sword that's designed to kill gods
now what this does is it basically gives
us this little bit of information that
tells us that the necro sword was
designed for a myriad of different
purposes of the sword is designed to
kill gods but is very much one of these
weapons where its capabilities and its
level of power it's relative to whatever
it's going against or at least that
seems to be the case and so when Gorda
God Witcher is using it to kill God the
weapon has enough power to kill God but
when or is using the necro sword it
amplifies his existing powers and allows
him to take on Galactus now at this one
Galactus is in a pretty weakened state
and that's the other half of this
equation Galactus whatever it is that he
uses is power cosmic it's just like a
battery right it's not an infinite
source of power sounds like telepathy
it's not like the optic beams and
cyclopses eyes it is a finite amount of
power it's not unlimited
and so as Galactus uses the power cosmic
it's like a battery that's just kind of
slowly draining now the other half of
this is that the hungrier Galactus gets
the more desperate the more ravenous and
the more dangerous he gets the lower his
patients get and so if the life is for
example it showed up on earth and was
absolutely starving and this conflict it
started it never would have gone on this
one he would have just been like and
you're done now and he would have just
you know obliterated Thor out of
existence
killed his granddaughter's when they
showed out this thing would have been
three pages long and then Galactus would
have consumed the earth and that would
have been it but the fact that he's
getting hungrier this actually is using
more of his powers means that now he's
beginning to get more irritated and he's
beginning to get more desperate now this
is kind of the cool thing here is
because once four arrives back on the
scene with this necro sword he
absolutely decimates Galactus I mean he
literally just kind of plunges the sword
right through him and that's really
about it now again this is kind of a
quick ending I mean it's not something
grandiose it's not something absolutely
insane things come to an end quick fast
and in a hurry but it is this idea that
with the necro sort you know Thoris
entually has a power of a thousand gods
and going through kind of declaring
himself for the destroyer finding
against Galactus and basically taking
Galactus down what this does is it
basically just kind of Sims Galactus
running Sims and basically saying okay
look this battle is far more than it's
worth I mean you're really more of a
hassle and you're worth of this point
now this is also compounded by the fact
the Galactus physical form is absolutely
tattered I mean it's always in complete
and total ruins just because of the fact
that the battle has been so extreme so
again at this point in this conflict
we're talking about a level of power
that's so high up there that normal
people couldn't even fathom what it is
that's going on but what it does is it
also sits down and it says even if Thor
right now is not strong enough to go
against Galactus he will be he will face
off against Galactus somewhere along the
line and he will probably be successful
in doing so
the other half of this is that following
this skirmish Thor actually bleeds on to
the ground of Earth and the earth begins
to just repopulate and regrow now this
is not just a random thing this is not
Jason Aaron just saying yeah man like
the blood of gods repopulate earth Thor
also has the four-four so he has the
entire energy of Odin imbued to himself
the other half of this is that Freya is
not the biological mother of four the
biological mother of four is gaia
basically the physical manifestation of
Mother Earth and so because of that Thor
is basically taking the life energy of
gaia and just kind of filling it out
there on earth that's essentially what's
happening what this tells us is that
somewhere along the line the earth will
return to its normal self in the earth
will he'll just kind of regrow and
populace will begin to come back and you
know humans will begin to grow and so on
and so forth we don't know how long that
process will take but we know that it
will but with the earth basically having
been restored the rivers and streams and
so on and so forth we actually end up
picking up with this epilogue and what
we find out is that with this all-black
necrose or basically having been you
know attached to Galactus you know that
Galactus himself actually ends up this
sort of evolving and kind of growing and
imbuing himself with the necros sword
and then somebody goes forward as the
butcher of worlds the sad thing about
this is we never find out what happens
next that's the worst part about all
that because I was like I really want to
see like Galactus the butcher of worlds
like I really want to see that happen I
really want to see when is up taking
place here but the problem is we don't
we never get to see that we never
actually get to see what takes place is
that Galactus is just kind of forced to
consume Mars and that's really about it
but in any event if you guys are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys
the set button to become part of the
rob4 if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like but yeah I will
catch you all later please
[Music]
[Applause]